Now that Grant's has such great ideas from the glasses expo about how to run his
business, and how to make all of his different products better, he's ready to
get his glasses wipers, and nozzles onto the market. That means that it's time
to talk about profit again. A while ago, Grant picked out some prices for his
wipers and his nozzles, but he wants to use the algebra skills we've taught him,
to check out if these really are the best choices he can make. So let's revisit
the idea of profit for a moment. If profit, which we'll call p, is equal to the
money that Grant earns, minus the money that he spends, and if we call money
spent m, then can you write an equation for profit, involving just single letter
variables? Assume that the money that they earned is only coming from wipers,
and that the number of wiper sets sold is equal to n, and the price per wiper
set is equal to c.